[音楽]
[拍手]
私たちはいつも[音楽]ジャンプについてテクノロジーのことをしてきました。
ハワイの投票は
私の生活空間を変えることで先生だったので、
来る最大のこと
は変化であり、私が住んでいる場所は
何でもあります。 先月の
名誉ある海岸の中間で、
いつもそこに住んでいたわけではありませんでした。
ソフィアで働いていたのですが、大学の
説明であなたの生活空間を変えました。
日本のアパートのほとんどのドアが
1.8メートルにあるので、それは1つの問題でした。
小さな子供がいて、
別の男の子のクライアントがいて、
近所の人が
[音楽]
[音楽]のこれらのノイズを
非常に近く
で見てい
ます。
まだどうしようかと思ったので家を建て始めましょう
[音楽]
だから、
運が良ければ本を切ったときに始めた
ので、基本的には1回前のことでした。
残念ながら、ほとんどの場合、ほとんどの場合、
パーツが簡単に外れることはありません。
テキサスの無情
[音楽]
パートナーがドライバーに
カメラを下ろしてリラックスしてくれてありがとう
、アランと一緒に自然の週
に火が燃えるので、対流 永遠にストーブをしますが、私
はすべてをスムーズにまとめることを考えていました。
ボブがやりたくないことを何もしたことがない友達を私たちに与えるため
に来た
たくさんの友達がい
ます。 たくさんの人が来
て助けてくれました。もちろん、妻と私
もこれに携わっていました。
彼女の家族もハムをくれた
ので、週末のふりをしてくれましたが、
後悔することはできません。お祝いの時間です。
その部分のために
fです 私が神であったときの間に、おがくず
を持っている人たちがもっと激しくいる必要はありませんでした。
放射線は
シャンパンであったか、お祝いは難しい部分で家族を解決します。
これは
私たちがリラックスして持ち込むことができるものの1つでした
最善を尽くす専門家
はあなた自身のシリーズを行う
ので、これはあなたから何人かの大工を手に入れ
ました。長い仕事の間に
彼らがやり始めたのは
難しいかもしれません。
私たち自身の限界についてです私たち
ができないこと私たち
ができないことそして私たちが
これらのいくつかを通過しているのを見るだけであなたは
彼らが半分をすくっているところを見ることができます私
は他のロングの上にその欠陥を見ました
とても美しいので、そのような音が
たくさん出ます。エネルギーを削減しようとはしていません。
大きなごちゃごちゃしたように、
この警備員の中に家を建てて、
建物を動かします。
庭全体が何週間も無駄になっ
ているので、ホストアーキテクチャが
大きな庭であることがわかります。これは、実際に基礎で起こっていたのと同じ時間ではありません。
そこにいる人々は、他の
ビジネス教育
住宅と同じように、強力な基礎が必要です。
基礎をチェックして、
この本を神に捧げるのにどれだけの深さが必要かを確認するために、私
は機械を使用するのに苦労しました。彼
は非常に機会
がありました。家がその状況に行く場所にコンクリートを置いてくれてありがとう。
週の4日間のものを再び配置して、すべての
ものをまとめます。最終的には、
財団が友達になり、すべてがやってくるのを見ることができました。
彼らは
正気を失いました。
もちろん、政府が物事
を言っていて
、ロマーニのトラックが持ってきた家です。
私たちは実際に住むことができたホストとの賭けをやめ、
住ん
でいる家の種類を実際に感じるために物を聞くことができました
トムはゆっくりと、しかし確実に
再び形を整えているので、これはすべて数ヶ月にわたって行われ、
そこを見回し終えました。あなたが見た私道は、最初は立ち上がら
なくなるかもしれません。
そこにあるすべての家を見ることができます。 紫外線
からそれらを保護するための法律を今では写真に記載する必要は
ないので、一度私たちがやっ
たら、ローカストの寿命を失うのを助けるできるだけ暗くするために他の節約をしたいのであれば同じかもしれません
今日、紫外線から、あまりにも軽すぎない
ことを強調するために狂気の長さになります
-
もちろん、私たちが言っていることはもちろん、
ゆっくりと再び明らかに狂気になりますが、確かに
私たちが家のように見え始めていることがわかります
形になっているええ、
話は
彼らが使用したかったものの1つであり、それは
一定期間にわたって続いています。私たちは実際
にホワイトハウスが
光が上がっているように見えるのを止める方法を見ること
ができます
そのような言葉の90 最初の段階は
最初の反復で、ほとんど
すべての染色が終了したので、祝うのは辛いです。そうすれば
、NSAの実行に進むことができます。部分的には
、日常生活ではないので、最初
にたくさんの断熱材を入手することです。 これ
は、物理学の冷却が上がったということ
です。家の中で凍らせたくないので、ワイヤー
を舗装する断熱材がたくさんあります。
私は必要ないので、子供たちが遊んで
いる途中で彼がどこかに行っていたようなものはありません。
5つのイベントまたは拍手を開い
て、ツリーオープナーの悪魔のモリスを包括的に調べているエキサイティングなジョークを見つけることができ
ます
。それらが豊富で問題がないことを知っている
ので、私たち
はダイニングエリアの作業も開始しました。
ダイニングキッチンになり
ましょう私たちが働くキッチンが大きくなる私は学校についての重要な
議論なので、これ
の半分は火室です残りの半分は
、6つのピザの電子ブックスペースを利用すれば、ここでフードトークをすることができます
レポートのトップ
非常にクールな素朴なスタイルのパーティー
とても素朴に見えたのはとても楽しい
ですが、ハイテクも私の作業スペース
ですこれらのモニターは両方とも上がることができます私たちは向きを
変えることができます花とキーボード
を上げることができます これ
が私の仕様にぴったり合っていない場合、
私の身長は目です。これまでに働いたどのオフィス
よりも多くの作業がありますが、それは非常に多くの作業です。
私が住んでいるスペース
は、家の一部が
最終的な作業に直面するようにカスタマイズします。
私たちが必要とするいくつかのことを実行したいこの沈んだリビングルーム
3つのサイズの窓青い
実験的な森と私の方法があり
ます 私の金にあなたは彼らの後ろの森の庭を見ることができます
それは
何かが成長しているように見えます
そしてそれは冬の覆いが破壊されたように見え
ます
また、
私たちが3つ持っていたのは、日本の優先住宅ではありません。
多くの剣を追加することにし
ました。また、正確に消えてしまうものもある
ので
、家の新しいスペースではなく、すべての段階で
何が起こっているのでしょうか。 市場にも出回っているので
、子供たちが関わりたいと思っていた庭
の周りのフェンス越しに歌っていて、それが彼の足にあると思います
[音楽]
子供たちが走り回っているなら良いです
残念ながら、テネシー
で起こっていることは、私たちが彼らに
再び見ることができるドライブウェイを与えるときに起こっています
[音楽]
近くでも
なので、2017年の創造的なプロセス
は私の性質の中で多くのことが起こりました
これは特に、チャパティについてのゲージング
のクラスを楽しむと言った生徒たちの
ために来た水です。
そのプロセスを経ることで、
教師がより良いレベルの環境での集会の生活を助けてくれた
ので、
私は本当に成長しました。
これはあなたがあなたの人生を守らないのは難しいことです
あなたが人間である方法を変えるだけ
であなたの人生で何をするかそれらの変化には多くの
ことがありますがあなたの人生の他の部分は
待っていません
ありがとうと思いました
[音楽]
[拍手]